hey guys it's Justine and we were back
talking about more iPhone updates and
this actually came out a few days ago so
this isn't really that new but it was
something that I wanted to talk about
because as you guys know I was a huge
fan of the iPhone 10 our colors that
came out last year I thought the colors
were gorgeous I did an entire unboxing I
also did a really fun giveaway with
Jonathan it's interesting though how
these new colors were leaked it was
actually leaked because of broken
colored glass so this is kind of insane
like it came from this tweet from mark
and it's showing here these broken
pieces of the glass so you can see this
like teal color and then there's like a
light yellow and then this purplish
color and obviously the white which
looks probably fairly similar to the
previous color which could lead us to
these two new colors this lavender and
mint
I think these colors are super realistic
because the last Apple watch bands that
they would be stored in their spring
lineup we're basically featuring these
two colors these two fellows were the
main highlight in addition to the papaya
color so I guess they kind of already
have the coral color which was very
similar to the papaya so if there's any
correlation between the Apple watch
bands and what iPhone colors will be
coming out next I think it's an
extremely realistic color so the camera
setup is also sort of interesting and
you guys can see here another tweet from
mark you might hear oh I'm not following
you I need to be following mark so this
is between mark is showing some iPhone
case mouldings and there are obviously
have been rumors of the next ten are
will have a dual camera setup which
would be pretty awesome and of course
probably the higher-end iPhones will
have the three camera setup as you guys
can see here and I'm pretty excited
about those colors though that lavender
and mint I like this photo a lot - this
is from 95 Mac so it sure wasn't what
those new colors would look like next to
all of the previous versions of the
iPhone 10 of our colors it's your
favourite iPhone 10 hour color I'm gonna
go when I looks like everyone's favorite
color is the red really surprised what
else is Mark been tweeting about because
clearly I'm his new biggest fan so this
is the coral color from last year I
should probably go get my phones
hold on a second here all the Apple
watch spring band colors and like I said
they are super into the mint lavender
and the papaya colors but these are all
the colors so let's just take a little
visualization of what would the mint and
the lavender look like against all of
these guys so let's see it looks like
they were gonna be removing two of the
colors I think it was like the blue so
blue and coral you guys are gonna have
to go away I'm not excited about what
about too excited about that I love the
coral color it doesn't really make sense
especially in the scheme of these
although maybe the coral didn't sell as
well so that's how they decided that
that one has to go people always talk
about like crazy cat ladies and stuff
like that well I'm definitely crazy
iPhone lady and I think I'm okay with it
this is that was mostly just talking
about the iPhone 10 our colors I thought
I would just do a quick little search to
see if there were any more iPhone 11
links and it looks like some of the
articles are saying that this is it
this is going to be the iPhone 11 like
it's going to look like this this is act
oh my gosh this is actually a render by
concept creator I love his channel he's
so talented and so incredible and oh my
gosh this is great
you guys have never checked out his
channel I definitely recommend you do so
he's so so good he creates such
incredible beautiful renders oh my gosh
these are all from him I'm so excited
and they have a little video his videos
look like Apple commercials look at this
this is beautiful
and it's got like some real Apple ish
music so based on leaks this is it so
this is concept creators the video this
is the the official design what
potential it would be our iPhone 11 now
that we have potentially seen the next
iPhone and all of the next 10 art colors
I'd love to know what you guys think I
know I'm super into the lavender and the
mint color I'm not sure which one I
would get if I had to choose but I
probably oh my gosh I'm not sure it
really is a toss-up because purple is
one of my favorite colors but also it
was really hoping for a hot pink phone
like this if this color the coral is
great but it's not hey I honestly think
a pink phone would do very very well I
don't think they've ever had a pink
phone like they've had like the rose
gold phones like just picture a phone
that Barbie would have liked that's what
I want
I know maybe a potentially stereotypical
but I want maybe not this time maybe
we'll just be getting the lavender in
the mint which I feel something I just
can't decide I like the lavender do I
like the mint more this is really
difficult I need you guys tell me in the
comments which one do you like more if
you were me if you're you also tell me
what you would like but if you were me
which one was I like so we'll be
interesting to see which colors they do
decide to knock out will it be the blue
in the coral like most of the rumors are
saying and obviously judging by that one
pool it seems like red is the most
popular color so I guess time will tell
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you guys are subscribed and also
like I said and go check out concept
creators channel I absolutely love his
channel he does such a great job with
render so go check him out and I think
that's all I have for you guys today I
just wanted to catch up really quickly
on what the latest was on the iPhone
news I just can't wait until it's
actually iPhone time it really is one of
my most favorite times of year so that's
I'm gonna go out of this video and I
will see you guys in the next
[Music]